[Music]
congratulations
this issue is amazing in grass and all
because of you right here oh no I'm as
good as the sum of my parts and right
here has a lot to do with that oh my
gosh right so you posed what like hours
after you gave birth my wish it was just
hours when did you shoot this um what
was I you you're five months out five
months out yeah but I guess like nothing
is better than motivation to get your
body after baby back then you know
posing and SS but also knowing that
you're working with people that are so
accommodating of your body not one
person was like okay can you let's let's
maybe hide this let's do this like no
they just wanted you to embrace it and
that's very cool thing this year in
particular sub rates women of all
different shapes and sizes and ages my
Sports Illustrated swimsuit has been
going in that direction you know for
actually quite some time and that really
bothers me as a as a human that women in
general evaluate themselves because
maybe they're a size 10 now and they
used to be a size eight and they beat
themselves up for that I don't Lauren
Sports Illustrated swimsuit to be the
colony when aspired me too because
honestly I was so stuck on the scale
game like I was the kind of person that
was you know pre-baby I weighed myself
three times a day you start to realize
like it's not about that number on the
scale it's about how you project
yourself it's those suits that you wear
it's it's I think this issue does more
for people than anyone will ever know
the misconception is that when your mom
or when you have children all of a
sudden you're not as good as you used to
be and I think that certainly all the
women that I know are better when I've
told you this this is your best year
ever you're sexier after a baby because
you own this body now in a way that
you've never owned it before I did feel
sexier when I was pregnant though I will
say that like I would have shot this
thing nine months pregnant I swear it
would have bled I remember
you